not every video on the Internet is real
and the fake ones are multiplying that's
thanks to the spread of deep fakes deep
fakes are videos that have been altered
using machine learning a form of
artificial intelligence to show someone
saying or doing something that they did
not in fact do or say the results can be
great fun take for example these
hilarious clips of Nicolas Cage starring
in movies that he was never in but deep
fakes can also be a tool for harassment
and a way to spread political
misinformation to learn more about the
deep fakes era we live in I spoke with
Sam Gregory who tracks these videos at
the Human Rights nonprofit witness what
is a deep akin and where did they come
from why are we talking about them all
of a sudden what deep fakes are the next
generation of video and audio
manipulation and sometimes images
they're based on artificial intelligence
and they make it much easier to do a
range of things so what people think of
as a deep fake is typically the Face
Swap right you take the face of one
person you transfer it onto another
person but we might also think within
the same category of other forms of
synthetic media manipulation like the
ability to manipulate someone's lips and
perhaps sync them up with a fake or real
audio track dolls or the ability to make
someone's body move or appear to move in
a way that is realistic but is in fact
computer-generated and all of this is
driven by advances in artificial
intelligence particularly the use of
what are known as generative adversarial
networks and in these adversarial
networks they have the capacity to set
to artificial intelligence networks
competing against each other one
producing forgeries the other competing
to detect the forgeries and as the
forgeries improve they do it based on
this competition between two networks so
this is one of the big challenges
underlying debates is that often they
are improving because of the nature of
the inputs there are so many different
ways you could use that technology what
are we seeing out there in the wild at
the moment they're primarily
non-consensual sexual images probably up
to 95 percent of the deep fakes out
there are images of celebrities or their
non-consensual images of ordinary people
being shared on on sites or being shared
in close messaging we have started to
see some other cases of debates being
used in other contexts targeting women
gern
or civic activists with images that
appear to show them in in sexual
situations we've also started to hear
people using that it's a deep fake
excuse so in the small number of
political level cases where there was
potentially a deep fake you see people
weaponizing the phrase it's a deep fake
and an almost in that case it's really a
version of the same phrase it's fake
news and Sam tell us how easy this
technology has become to access you
mentioned that that it's improved can
anyone do this it's still not at the
point that anyone can do a a really
convincing Face Swap keepsake there's
code available online there are websites
you can go to that will allow you to
create a fake you know some of those
deep fakes will be imperfect but we also
know that imperfect deep fakes can still
cause harm so it's getting more
accessible because it's getting
commercialized commoditized and what's
become clear in the last six months is
the deep fakes and also other synthetic
media like audio generation is getting
better and better and requiring less
training data
less less examples you need to generate
the data all of which mean we're gonna
get more and more of this content and
it's probably gonna be both better and
better quality in Congress there has
been concern about defects being used to
distort political campaigns maybe even
the twenty20 presidential campaign right
there's clearly vulnerabilities for
political candidates for that you know
the last-minute surprise for
compromising video a lot of attention
goes to political candidates there are
detection methods being developed for
those political candidates to protect
them from deep fakes and the reason
people worry about the advances in deep
fakes and in other synthetic media is
we've really seen quite significant
progress in the last six to twelve
months we've seen you know decline in
the amount of training data needed down
to you know a few images for some of the
face expression modification we've seen
people starting to combine video
manipulation like the lips with
simulation of audio and we're starting
to see the commercialization of this
into apps and as things go to mobile
that increase them as they become apps
they also get much more available and
this is why it puts the pressure to be
saying how we making sure that as these
get more available they're detectable
and that app makers also think about
detection at the same time as they think
about creation because they'd have a
Pandora's box there and we've already
seen how a Pandora
box like that can be unleashed what
possible solutions are people talking
about you mentioned the idea of a
technical solution I guess you know the
ideal thing would be something like a
spam filter spam filtering is pretty
good these days you don't see much spam
could we do that for deep face just
block them out we could but we'd have to
define what we think is a malicious deep
fake right because you know deep fakes
and all this genre of synthetic media I
really you know that they're related to
computational photography doing a funny
face filter on an app now you might say
that's fun that's my granny or you might
say that's great you know I think it's
great that that's a satire of my
president or you might look and say I
want to check this against another
source what we're not doing actually at
the moment is telling people how to
detect deep fake so with technical
clothes and the reason for that is each
of those glitches is the current
algorithmic kind of Achilles heel right
it's the problem of the current version
of the algorithm but as we put different
data into the algorithm as we recognize
that's a problem it's not going to do
that so for example a year ago people
thought the deep lakes didn't really
blink and now you see defects that blink
now there are technical solutions they
are all going to be partial solutions
and we should want them to be partial
solutions there's a lot of investment in
detection using advanced forms of media
forensics the problem with all those
approaches is that they always are at a
disadvantage the attacker has the
advantage there with the new technique
and can learn from the previous
generations of creation and forgery and
forgery detection substituting a kind of
technical check check mark for human
reasoning is not a great idea both
systems like that get broken there are
absolutely honeypot for hackers and
people who want to disrupt it and also
because these things are complex right
you know it you know something may look
real and that may not matter to us that
it has had some manipulation and you
don't want to give that across and
something may have a tick mark but in
fact the context is all wrong I tend to
think of detection as being the thing
that at least gives us some signals some
signals that might help us say actually
there's something suspicious here I'm
going to need to use my media literacy
I'm going to have to think about it
well that's interesting you mentioned
you know the question of how people
should think differently now that we're
in the deep fake era you might call it I
guess it was never a good idea to
believe everything you saw on the
internet and now you can't believe
anything you see know what's the right
what's the right mindset to have I think
it's also a problem
generally with the misinformation
disinformation discussion is we've
convinced people they can't believe
anything online when the reality is much
of what shared online is true or true
enough it does increase the pressure on
us to recognize that photos and text are
not necessarily trustworthy we need to
use our media literacy on them to assess
where it came from is there
corroboration and what's complicated
about video and audio is we have a
different cognitive reaction we don't
have the filters we've either built or
cognitively have around text and photo
so I think a real onus on both platforms
you have the capacity to be looking to
this but also people who build the tools
that are starting to create this to feel
a responsibility to yes build great
tools for creation but also to build
tools for detection and then we can plug
that into a culture that where we're
really saying you do need media literacy
you do need to look at content and
assess it and I don't think that's the
same as saying it's the end of truth I
think it's saying you know we have to be
skeptical viewers how do we give them
technical signals how do we build the
media literacies that will deal with
this latest generation of manipulation
well Sam thank you very much for your
help understanding defects
thank you Tom I appreciate the interview